hey guys make a note for nightmare so
even before we started this video we
started getting into like LARPing a
little bit which is kind of funny so we
are a friend to Adam Lions came over and
was like hey guys I'll do for a shoot I
got all these LARPing swords so he
brought over all these foam weapons one
day so we could start practicing and he
helped us start choreographing the moves
we're really looking forward to Skyrim
and we've always kind of wanted using
the swords we're like let's make it
oblivion video and then we realized that
let's just let's just not make a
straight-up oblivion video let's go you
try like an RPG ish inspired by all the
little jokes and moments that we
remember from those games we want to do
this piece and make it look really
authentic and we tweeted out saying
we're looking for some people with like
sweet swords and stuff like that and
just by chance we got a guy named John
contacted us on the if she runs a
youtube channel he just launched it like
what and he has told friends that
they're really into like the Renaissance
Faire historical recreations and stuff
like that so they actually they'll show
about him and Dan and Tom and they've
awesome gear it was really really cool
and Dan is actually really good with
weapons this movie would not have been
possible without their help and I think
that's something that you know anybody
who's making movies quickly learns is
that without the help of other people
and then you know having a group to draw
from it's really hard to make something
like
the best movies are team effort with a
lot of people anyways I'm sure you guys
are wondering where did you shoot this a
shot in the park counted out by Chino
Hills it's really hot up 100 degrees out
yeah and it's funny cuz the first day I
was like oh whatever I'm just gonna wing
it
whatever so I run out there in this like
almost full suit of armor we started
with the fight right away and I nearly
collapsed and I'm sitting there lying on
the ground and I was like alright you
you cool yeah just give me five minutes
like didn't Pamela snow then throw up
manage to finish the fight we drink a
lot of water basically like for eight
hours we're doing some constant water I
didn't pee all day that's all hot it was
it's actually really funny you know the
shot where I take my arrow and I shoot
that barbarian well it's really funny
because in that shot you don't see the
rest of it maybe we'll play it here but
right when I shoot it it flies over a
ridge everyone turns watch the arrow go
flying over the ridge and they turn back
to me so Sam
you almost hit somebody like we've
literally seen zero people out here
today we've been here for five hours you
guys are all playing a prank on me their
heads turn again perfect coordination
I'm like this is gonna be a really
well-planned joke from the for them to
you know organize this and then the guy
comes over the hill holding the arrow is
like oh you almost hit me totally cool
little bit thanks guys for being cool
anyways the effects actually on this
piece we're not that extensive we had
some cool brutal sword kills and some
lightning bolts that's about it and like
an arrow yeah compared to dubstep guns a
two and a half minute piece with around
50 to 60 VFX shots this was a you know
four minute Pete's with about a dozen so
anyways for the sword effects we want to
be you know basically how people get
stabbed and the sword go through them
and to do that we did an object track on
the person basically we have a rough 3d
model it tracks it to the person and we
didn't have an object like a CG sword
seem to actually stick to the person we
were able to take it a little bit
further and actually have like a gas
open up and actually have a contract the
guy and the motion really sells the
Adventure Time video is a great warm-up
for this effect and then also the part
where Dan's arm gets a child
initially the arm flew off but we
couldn't get the motion to look right in
natural facts I just have to like
keyframe it by hand so I was sitting
there the morning uh we were gonna
release it and just tweaking with it and
I was like wait a second you just have a
dangle and then I was like no that's too
gross and but I did it anyways it's so
gross I'm sitting there like Nico this
is too gross he's like no lightning bolt
for the Lightning effect is basically
combination of things one the dubstep
gun laser I used a lot of similar
techniques from that but also on top of
that I also used what After Effects
likes to call it's obsolete lightning
filter now if you ask me it looks pretty
good so for the shot basically don't
take the lightning charge it up the
track it in 3d space for the deflection
I'd have a little particle burst explode
out and bounce off the ground then I
toss some lens of lightness in there and
use it all over again for a ripple layer
that goes on top here's a cool shot for
you guys that Matt painting in the
beginning now I think this is obviously
one of the best matte paintings I've
ever done and here's why so like a basic
matte painting you start out with adding
your elements boom toss a little Hut in
there boom toss the castle wall boom
thompson castle in the background here's
the kicker i use the plugin called shine
to actually take the sky and create a
like a false sense of volumetric light
shining over the hills light rays
essentially and i think that is the
effect that really sells it here makes
it look really realistic blends
everything together it's beautiful take
a look nice work Sam
thanks oh another topic that we rarely
go into is music and I just find it very
hard to talk about for some reason
regardless because it comes from in here
that's the thing when it comes down to
it doesn't matter what program you're
using it's what comes from the heart and
this this little like flute medley kind
of thing came from my heart
but more than anything else when I do a
soundtrack for a piece especially one
like this that has a lot of dynamic
shifts is basically you have to pay
attention to what's happening in the
scene and what's about to come and see
you want you want to make sure you it's
tailored to the excitement and energy
levels that are coming and going also
one of the things it's very useful to
stick to as very little themes as
possible you don't want to have too many
abrupt musical shifts going from Team A
to C to B indeed and even though I do it
a lot in my pieces I do try and make
sure that each theme is grounded and
repeats itself so that the audience can
familiarize themselves with the melodies
and hear them coming in and out of the
piece as you know the seat shifts Sam
uses logic and a bunch of stuff I use
logic and I use this bass guitar anyways
guys thanks for watching I hope you
liked the video we don't get a new stuff
with swords very often or nights so it's
actually kind of a really nice break
from the norm it's a lot of fun just
going out to nature like chopping at
each other with axes and large metal
knives
real metal knives yeah okay I want to
say thanks to Adam I want to say thanks
to John and thanks to Dan and Tom I'll
do you guys with YouTube channels of
ours I think um - well yeah you guys
made this possible so
I hope you're proud of what you did oh
and guys if you have any questions get
us on Twitter and Facebook too but
Twitter's better for us to answer
questions Britney's follow Facebook's
across democracy tendencies